If we've learned
anything from that Kendall
Jenner commercial, it's that any
issue can be exploited for
corporate financial gain with
zero negative repercussions.
(laughter)
So with Earth Day coming up,
it's only natural that a bunch
of old rich dudes would flip the
script on climate change for
their own gain.
So it might as well be the Koch
brothers.
An organization funded by...
>> Hey!
>> Koch boys.
>> The Koch boys are in the
building.
>> HARDWICK: There they are.
(laughter)
>> HARDWICK: There's an
organization funded by the
right-wing,
climate-change-denying,
billionaire turtle men who were
involved in over 300 oil spoils.
>> Wow!
>> HARDWICK: And they want you
to celebrate this Earth Day by
celebrating fossil fuels.
So, the Earth Day Fossil Fuels
Art Contest implores us to,
"Celebrate the trucks that
deliver the trees, or the gas
that powers the truck, or the
plastic handles of the shovels
they use."
Aah!
>> All right, let's not...
>> HARDWICK: This makes no
sense.
It's like celebrating Christmas
by stealing Xboxes from orphans.
It doesn't really make sense.
(laughter)
"No, I'm gonna steal from the
orphans and give to the rich
kids.
See how it works?"
>> Duh.
>> HARDWICK: Anyway, whoever
wrote this is the same person
who says stupid shit like, "Why
can't it be called 'Father
Earth'?"
So...
(laughter)
>> Gotti!
>> HARDWICK: The Independence
Institute is accepting
submissions of original art work
celebrating fossil fuels until
tomorrow.
I've already submitted mine.
All natural.
>> Yeah.
>> HARDWICK: All natural.
It's organic. It's organic.
>> Nice.
(applause and cheering)
>> HARDWICK: So, comedians, how
would you celebrate fossil
fuels?
Stephanie.
>> By putting a plastic bag over
my head and murdering a seagull.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
>> Hey.
(laughter)
Desus.
>> I'm gonna drive in a stretch
limo through a field full of
endangered pandas.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
(laughter)
Mero.
>> I am going to fly my private
jet from the Bronx to Queens.
>> HARDWICK: All right, perfect.
>> Hey.
>> Shit.